[Musique]
des images très warholienne cinquante
ans plus tard le pop art du toujours
sous le pinceau de benjamin starke
l'artiste franco belge s'inspire de tout
ce qu'il voit le cinéma la publicité
le dessin de presse
je fouine les images fouine les
informations je fouine ce que les
graphistes font les autres artistes les
cinéastes j'essaie de me nourrir un
maximum de ça de toute cette culture qui
environnent pour ensuite créer des
montages des décollages et essayer de
percevoir des éléments qui pourraient
coller ensemble qui pourrait commencer à
être un embryon de narration du noir du
blanc et de couleurs et des oeuvres
sentent il faut pour laisser toute
l'interprétation regardeur comme il les
appelle pour porter une réflexion autour
d'un thème la violence
l'actualité du monde est tellement
dingue de toute façon que ça donne envie
de s'exprimer
on retrouve sur les tableaux ce qu'on
retrouve dans l'actualité des armes d
explosion de la violence et c'est un
exutoire c'est évidemment une première
façon d'appréhender la violence étant
particulièrement axé sur la non violence
sur la fin de la guerre au plus vite sur
l'arrêt immédiat de l'intervention de la
france par exemple où la belgique au
moyen-orient j'aimerais faire passer au
moins ce message là si je peux à travers
ce genre de tableaux l'artiste marie les
techniques d'aujourd'hui impression
laser et numériques logiciels
informatiques qui lient aux matières
nobles peintures toiles de lin bois un
univers très actuel qui mêle un héritage
de bande dessinée
[Applaudissements]